well in a perverse sense for people like
me the crisis had a nice effect because
frankly this is what I do is search on a
models of so-called financial
accelerators what happens when you get
into financial crises what happens to
investment what happens to consumer
spending a lot of people like me have
been working this area have generally
relied on historical episodes because
that's where you soon crises so now we
have you know unfortunately an episode
during the modern period what we know in
those periods is that when you get into
a financial crisis the inside net worth
of borrowers becomes very very important
this is what we saw in the collapse of
consumer spending is consumer net worth
decline and in a business sector as the
cost of external financing became very
high as credit spreads became very high
we also though have a sense of what to
do in an environment like this very
aggressive monetary policy is part of
the answer we did that with the Federal
Reserve tax cuts can be part of the
answer so I think policy has been very
aggressive today much more aggressive
than it was saying Japan in the 1990s or
in the US and the 1930s taking a crisis
that was very bad but making it not as
bad as it could have been
I'm very worried about this we have
essentially a set of deficit problems in
the country the very short run I'm not
sure that we should worry so much about
the extra deficit that was used to help
attack the financial crisis I think it's
very important to be very aggressive did
the Federal Reserve any administration
credit there I would have done Brooks a
different set of things in the
administration but their basic thrust
I'm ok with going toward the medium term
though we've seen a built-up both from
the Bush administration and now from the
Obama administration in significant
levels of spending that will have to be
paid for with future taxes and that
deficit is a real problem and then the
third deficit the one that scares me the
most is the long-term entitlement
deficit because of our promises for
Social Security and Medicare now if you
just let the clock run one generation 25
years we would be spending about ten
percentage points of u.s. gdp more on
just social security and medicare than
we do today and given that the whole
federal tax share today is nineteen
percent of GDP within sixty percent tax
increases for everybody that's obviously
not going to happen and so we're going
to have to come to grips with this at
some point bond markets will worry about
this and maybe a problem for interest
rates because bond market participants
will realize the u.s. is going to have a
very difficult problem these debt levels
if I were say one thing the president
obama right now will be focus focus
focus on getting that long-term deficit
down
well we have to figure out what our
expenditures are going to be your the
first order or fiscal decisions how much
you spend then you have a decision of
these taxes or borrow and we're
borrowing just future taxes I think for
the US our levels of spending promises
for the future again particularly
entitlement programs are so big we
really can't raise taxes enough to pay
for that I don't mean we can't buy
arithmetic that the amounts are so big
sixty seventy percent that's just not
going to happen even crater economic
growth so I think we really have to talk
a lot about how to scale back some of
these programs going forward and do so
in a way that keeps the least well-off
among us fine but asked for some
sacrifices frankly from those of us with
Monroe